Au commencement,
les hommes et les animaux
vivaient en harmonie sur Terre.
Les gobelins étaient prisonniers
dans une sombre prison des cieux.
Le grand archange joua de la flute
3000 jours durant
afin de contenir les gobelins.
Au bout du 3001ème jour
les portes devaient s ouvrir
mais à cause d'une erreur commise
par trois divinités taoïstes
elles furent ouvertes
un jour trop tôt.
Nous sommes-nous trompés de date ?
Il doit y avoir une erreur...
Cela fait bien 3000 jours
A ce moment-là,
le démon vivant parmi les gobelins
fut éveillé
et ses forces maléfiques
s'emparèrent de la flûte.
Tous les gobelins
voulaient en devenir le maître.
Ayant perdu la flûte,
l'archange fut consumé par le Mal
et tomba sur Terre.
- Archange !
- Que faire maintenant ?
- Votre Altesse !
- Archange, Altesse !
Votre Altesse !
Oui, un moine
qui attrape des gobelins...
Pourquoi vous n'avez pas fait
vos exercices avec les autres hier ?
Je vais vous confier que la vie
des hommes dépend des étoiles.
Mais de nos jours, on préfère penser
qu on dépend de l'ADN.
Vos exercices sont-ils si utiles ?
Les personnes âgées meurent
à force d'en faire trop
mais pourtant
elles continuent à courir.
Vous ne devez pas être d'accord,
puisque vous êtes médecin.
- C'était amusant d'être un dieu ?
- Mais je le suis toujours.
C'est un devoir, pas un jeu.
On est tous pareils.
On rit, on pleure tous et souvent,
on s'ennuie.
On perd espoir
tous les énièmes siècles.
Donc, j'ai inventé une pilule
pour tout oublier.
Je l'ai avalée.
J ai eu mal ici et là,
et mes souvenirs se sont effacés
puis j'ai erré dans les rues.
Il est noté ici,
que vous êtes sans domicile fixe.
Mais c est uniquement par choix.
Quel bel homme celui-là.
Mais je suis venu ici
et on me donne davantage de cachets.
Je les avale sans sourciller.
Dopamine et antidépresseurs.
Elles ont neutralisé mes pilules.
Avec eux,
j'ai retrouvé la mémoire...
Vous faisiez quoi
quand vous étiez une divinité ?
Je suis toujours une divinité,
voyons !
Je cherchais des gobelins.
Puis, on lui demande
de les attraper.
Ça va faire mal.
La blessure sera guérie dès demain.
Merci maître.
- Quel âge as-tu ?
- J'ai neuf ans, maître.
Oh...
C'est à toi de t occuper
de ton grand-père,
compris ?
- Oui.
Et moi alors ?
Je souffre le martyre !
Mais oui, bien sûr...
Vous allez quelque part ?
Oui.
Vous n'en aurez que la moitié.
Je vois.
Pourquoi revenez-vous
les mains vides ?
Je suis désolé, maître.
Cet imbécile est plus désobéissant
et violent que jamais, maître.
La blessure n'est pas très profonde.
On dirait bien
que l'imbécile a été clément.
Préparez-vous à partir.
Vos élèves se font malmener,
à ce que je vois...
Oui, je les envoie me chercher
un jeune magicien arrogant,
comme ça je pourrai le corriger.
De tels élèves ne peuvent pas être
d'une très grande aide
Je dois encore perfectionner
mes enseignements.
Tout ça à cause
de ces trois divinités ridicules.
Après 3000 jours,
ils ont commis l irréparable...
Et les portes se sont ouvertes.
Vous les connaissez ?
on les connaît...
comme si on les avait faites !
Quel grand thé !
C'est vrai ça !
Il chatouille les papilles.
Ce n est que de l eau chaude.
L eau est aussi chaude
qu'elle doit l'être.
La nuit va tomber.
On devrait se dépêcher.
Nous devrions finir le thé,
d'abord...
Il est très bon.
Bien sûr.
Après tout,
pourquoi aller si vite !
Consumés par le diable,
l'archange et les gobelins
s'enfuirent sur Terre en se cachant
dans les corps des humains.
Ils ne se souvenaient plus
de leur passé ni de leur identité.
Selon les rumeurs,
seul celui qui aurait la flûte
pourrait enfin
commander les gobelins.
Donc vous avez fini
par trouver la flûte de l'archange ?
On dit qu'un sorcier
de la province de Jeonra
l'a découverte il y a quatre jours
et qu'il a été assassiné peu après.
Il y avait du sang verdâtre
tout autour de la scène.
Nous avons suivi les traces de sang
jusqu'ici.
Je capturerai le gobelin
et vous ramènerai la flûte.
Hélas, depuis que nous avons
commis cette err
- Aucune erreur.
- Non, cela va de soi !
Je vous en prie, gardez la flûte,
maître Hwadam.
On ne peut pas faire confiance
aux autres magiciens malhonnêtes.
Oh ça non !
Il y a quelque chose sur le toit.
Là !
C'est un gobelin ?
- Comment puis-je...
- Tirons-lui dessus d'abord.
Attendez une seconde !
Il n'y a que les gobelins
qui courent sur les toits la nuit.
- Hwadam, tirez-lui dessus.
- Non, attendez.
- Est-ce bien un gobelin ?
- Laissez-moi une petite minute !
- Attendez.
- Il est juste là !
Mais il ne devrait pas rôder
sous sa forme de gobelin.
C en est un !
Un gobelin !
Maître Hwadam,
faites quelque chose !
Reprenez-vous...
Un talisman ?
Avez-vous demandé à un autre
de capturer les gobelins ?
Bien sûr que non.
On dirait pourtant
que cette flèche est à nous...
- On nous l a volée.
- Qui l a volée ?
Cette crapule de Woochi.
Woochi ?
Voici Monseigneur le prince
du royaume des cieux !
Montrez-lui votre respect !
Roi de la terre,
avez-vous envoyé dix mille pièces
d'or là où la famine fait rage ?
Oui votre Majesté.
Comme vous me l'aviez ordonné
en rêve.
Ne vous inquiétez pas,
Monseigneur.
Les cieux sourient
devant une telle action.
Lorsque vous retournerez
dans les cieux,
cela vous sera rendu
au quintuple...
ou peut-être même au centuple !
J'ai aussi apporté les trésors,
comme vous l'aviez demandé en rêve.
Des trésors plus brillants que vous,
roi de la Terre ?
Mais au fait...
où sont les jeunes femmes ?
Les jeunes femmes,
pourquoi ça, monseigneur ?
Silence !
Les cieux n'approuvent pas
l'oisiveté.
Elles pourraient me servir
un rafraîchissement.
Gardez votre musique,
elle m insupporte.
Combien de fois par jour
allez-vous à la selle ?
Vous voulez que je vous dise...
Ne soyez pas timide.
Allons, répondez...
Une fois tous les trois jours.
Et vous ?
Trois fois par jour, votre grâce.
Tu es en bonne santé, sers-moi.
Roi de la Terre,
relevez donc la tête.
J'ai toujours aimé la peinture...
Lorsque je peins un arbre,
il se met à pousser.
Quand je peins un animal,
il rampe hors du parchemin.
Quel grand talent,
vous en conviendrez ?
Que dites-vous de cette toile ?
La peinture respire la grandeur,
mon seigneur !
Et ce cheval solitaire symbolise
la solitude de l'homme.
- C'est absurde.
- Vous avez raison.
- Ce n'est qu un cheval pour moi.
- Oui, un cheval pour vous
Woochi ?
- Woochi, la crapule ?
- Vous avez entendu parler de moi !
Je ne peux aller nulle part
à cause de ma notoriété fatigante.
Tu oses te moquer du roi ?
Espèce de petit escroc !
Ha ha...
Je suis un magicien.
Qu'est-ce donc qu'un magicien ?
C est celui qui dirige les vents
qui réveille la pluie torride
qui fait des bonds dans l'espace...
Et qui, de son épée agile
dirige le monde !
Celui qui manie sa lame...
comme s il s agissait d une fleur !
Celui qui vient en aide...
aux plus faibles.
Le sommet !
Là où le déclin commence toujours !
Là ou le roi et ses sujets
ont failli au peuple famélique.
Mais moi, Woochi...
je suis là pour aider les pauvres,
sans qu on m'en félicite...
Je me demande ce qui va se passer
si je frappe le goulot de la fiole.
J'emporte avec moi le miroir du roi.
Allez chercher tous les magiciens.
Qu'ils m'attrapent cet imbécile !
Voyons cela
Woochi.
Tout à l heure...
la veuve se rendra au temple.
Il ne nous reste plus qu'à trouver
le sabre en bronze.
Avec le sabre et la veuve,
vous y êtes ?
tu seras enfin
un magicien de légende !
Ne regarde pas.
Tu regretterais de connaître
ta véritable identité.
C est ça, oui !
Je serai un magicien tout puissant
avec le miroir
et le couteau en main.
- Est-ce que tu as vu... la veuve ?
- Oui, je l ai vue !
De dos, mais je l ai vue !
Mais quel dos,
que courbes délicates...
Et le dos d une fille,
c est ce qu elle a de plus joli.
Vous avez vraiment vu
Maître Hwadam ?
Je l'ai vu s'élever dans le ciel !
Son mari est mort
lors de leur nuit de noce.
C'est pour cela que Hwadam
de l'ouest... est le meilleur !
- Oui, il soigne les maladies et...
- Oh, attendez...
On m a dit qu un autre magicien,
de la province de Pyongyang,
avait éradiqué la famine
Mensonges !
Hwadam de Kaesong est le meilleur.
Il y a des magiciens à Pyongyang ?
Je crois qu'il s'appelle Woo
Hé, le maître ne veux pas
que l on révèle nos noms !
- Un grand magicien qui s appelle
C'est ça, oui ! Woochi !
Nous sommes mandatés
par le grand maître Hwadam
afin de vous remettre à la justice
pour vous être moqués du roi
et pour le vol de dix mille
pièces d'or !
Crapule !
Vous avez besoin d aide ?
Ça ira !
Il en manque un.
Hwadam est-il toujours le meilleur ?
Non, c est sûr !
Votre nom, gentilhomme ?
Le nom du magicien
qui se trouve devant vous est
Sale brigand !
Que vais-je faire de ma taverne...
elle est en ruine !
- Et moi donc ?
- Payez.
Combien ?
Vingt pièces d'argent !
Je n'ai aucune monnaie sur moi.
- Je lui fais sa fête ?
- Lui faire sa fête ?
C est du travail d'équipe, ça !
Veux-tu qu on continue à se battre ?
On y va !
Nous devons enlever la veuve.
Maintenant ?
J ai une de ces douleurs
dans le dos.
Continue comme ça et je t attacherai
à nouveau dans un champ.
J ai assez brouté d herbe
ces temps derniers...
Hé, regarde-moi ça !
Une veuve
porte malheur dans un foyer
Si par malheur vous échouez,
utilisez ceci.
Nous réussirons, madame.
Nous trouverons des hommes
qui nous serviront de témoins.
Puis-je savoir ce que l on attend ?
Ce ne sera plus très long.
Nous attendons les derniers hommes.
D'accord.
Vous escaladez
cette montagne de la mort ?
Les gens y montent bien, mais
personne n'en est jamais revenu.
Je viens avec vous.
Je n'ai rien de mieux à faire.
Tu as peut-être fière allure,
mais tu ne sembles pas très robuste.
Je ne suis peut-être pas costaud
mais je sais dégainer l'épée...
- Mais tu n'en as même pas...
- Bien parlé. Tiens en voilà une...
Regardez ce fou.
Il se prend pour Woochi.
Ah, Woochi !
Même si je ne suis pas aussi
courageux, je viens quand même,
J ai les reins en compote...
Quand est-ce qu'on l'enlève ?
Dès qu on sera
au sommet de cette colline.
Attrapez-les !
Brigands !
Infirmière !
Qu'est-ce qu'il se passe ?
Ils attaquent la veuve, eux aussi ?
J ai un plan...
Tu vas chercher la veuve
et moi je me charge d'eux.
Dépêche toi de me retransformer.
Allez ! Claque des doigts.
Vous devriez apprendre la magie,
au lieu de me faire perdre du temps.
Infirmière !
Dégagez !
Je suis...
non, attendez
je suis
Infirmière !
A l'aide !
Maudite est la veuve
- Alors vous alliez...
- Maudite est la veuve...
Est-ce que ça va aller ?
Pourquoi me suivez-vous ?
Ce n'est pas facile à dire.
Je suis venu pour vous
Oh non ? C est donc cela ?
Oui.
Alors vous êtes
- amoureux de moi ?
- Oui. Quoi ?
Dites-moi toute la vérité.
Votre c ur bat donc pour moi !
Enfin, je suis venu
- pour vous, vous...
- Pour m aimer !
J'ai toujours su que
quelqu'un comme vous viendrait.
Votre parfum est délicieux
Pendant que j'attrape les bandits,
toi tu t'acoquines
avec la première venue...
Une veuve porte toujours malheur
dans un foyer !
Qu'est-ce qu'elle marmonne,
celle-là ?
C'est une diseuse de bonaventure !
Dites-moi, qui est votre acolyte ?
Ce n'est pas mon acolyte,
mais un chien galeux.
Au sens figuré, il va sans dire...
Je suis Chorangyi.
Vous sentez bon, vous aussi !
Peux-je vous serrez dans mes bras ?
Une aussi grossière compagnie
ne peut que vous causer des ennuis.
Je suis on-ne-peut-plus
d'accord avec vous.
Grossière ?
Dépêche-toi de la mettre là-dedans.
Des gens aussi gentils que nous
se font rares, madame.
Bon travail.
Je suppose que la hanche de père
est déjà guérie.
Dites-moi où se trouve
le sabre en bronze.
C est vrai...
Une charrette de cadeaux
est partie chez les ducs.
Le sabre doit s y trouver.
Nous sommes quittes, maintenant...
Les ducs ?
Donc on doit aller là-bas ?
La parole d'un homme instruit
n'a pas beaucoup de valeur.
Je suis l'infirmière !
Qui es-tu, intruse ?
Félicitations,
vous avez l'oreille fine...
Je crois qu il devrait y avoir
un sabre en bronze quelque part.
Tu m'as apporté la mauvaise fille,
imbécile !
Vous avez choisi
le mauvais magicien.
Assassins !
Protégez le maitre !
Que vas-tu faire avec ça ?
Pas ça !
Assassin ? Ne soyez pas ridicule.
Personne n'assassine personne !
Arrête d'entrer et de sortir !
Où est le sabre en bronze ?
- Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
- Arrêtez !
Vous savez qui c'est ?
Cette créature n'est pas votre père.
Comment oses-tu !
Père ? Ce sabre !
Capturez-le immédiatement !
J ai comme l impression que la nuit
va être très longue...
Pourquoi est-ce qu il me regarde
de travers ?
Je vois...
Il est temps de changer !
Je ne vois rien !
Ça va ?
Ça va !
Où est passée cette saleté de rat ?
Bon sang, qu'il est rapide.
Woochi !
Attention !
Derrière toi !
Woochi !
Attention
Ça brûle !
Woochi !
Espèce d idiot !
Relève-toi !
Woochi !
- Oh, la sale bête
Voilà un autre talisman
qui fera parfaitement l'affaire.
J'ai cru que tu étais vraiment mort,
cette fois !
Faites-lui avaler sa pipe !
Là, j'ai tout vu.
Bon, lui c'est un lapin !
Tire-toi de là !
Sale bête
Je te tiens !
Ah oui, la flèche !
Quoi ?
- Woochi ?
- La crapule ?
Un talisman
Le prieuré
de l'Est existe toujours ?
Chaque chose en son temps.
Nous devons retrouver la flûte !
Je crains que ce gobelin
n'ait hélas la flûte.
Deux gobelins capturés
mais hélas toujours pas de flûte.
C'est impossible.
Un magicien et un homme étrange
ont été aperçus avec la flûte.
Maître !
Pourquoi ne pas jeter un sort
et vous éviter tout ce travail ?
Mon garçon
La magie n'est qu'une illusion.
On n'en a pas besoin
pour ramasser des racines.
Que je suis idiot !
Ce gobelin a soufflé dans la flute
et a invoqué un autre gobelin.
Oui !
Et l'autre gobelin t'a demandé
de lui amener cette veuve ?
Hum-Hum.
Pourquoi l'as-tu enlevée pour lui ?
C est simple...
Woochi m a interdit de vous le dire.
Il cherchait le miroir et le sabre
à nouveau, c est ça ?
Non !
Et tu l'as suivi en pensant
qu'il ferait de toi un humain...
Le parchemin dit que ces choses
feront de lui un magicien puissant
Et il pourra
me transformer en homme.
Tu ne le connais toujours pas ?
Il ne cherche pas à améliorer
son art, mais à devenir célèbre.
Précisément, maître,
je lui ai d ailleurs demandé
comment il pouvait être
aussi arrogant.
Il a dit :
"On devait se mêler aux hommes
et profiter de la vie.
Ce vieux sorcier est fou et aigri".
En se référant à vous, maître
J'ai voulu le faire taire,
mais vous savez qu il est têtu.
Mais il fuit la solitude du taoïste
et rêve de réussite confucéenne,
oh pauvre de lui...
Il veut connaître la réalité
des choses, ce qui est bien...
Une façon comme une autre de tester
l étendue de ses connaissances.
Qu'est-ce que tu racontes ?
Maître...
est-ce que vous allez bien ?
Je vengeais votre mort
dans mon rêve.
Sa sottise m'ahurit...
Pauvre enfant,
il doit avoir de la fièvre, maître.
J'embrassais la veuve...
Et il n'a pas encore dessaoulé
Je vous envoie en mission mais
vous allez dans un palace.
Vous osez ridiculiser le roi,
et vous battez avec les gobelins
et vous enlevez une veuve !
À quoi bon être magicien, alors ?
Excellente question, oui...
Surtout de la part de quelqu un...
qui ne mérite pas
de devenir magicien.
Ça c est ce qu on verra, maître,
vous me sous-estimez.
Pourquoi dites-vous ça ?
Parce que tu ne sais pas
faire le vide dans ton esprit.
C est possible ça, vous croyez ?
Que fais-tu après avoir mangé ?
Je digère.
Après mangé,
tu dois d'abord laver la vaisselle.
Où sommes-nous ?
Nous sommes devant le temple
du prieuré de l'Est.
En route.
- Attendez ici.
- Oui maître.
Vous ne pouvez pas venir par ici.
Allez-vous en !
Qu est-ce que c est ?
Es-tu l'idiot qui dit être Woochi ?
Vous vous prenez pour qui ?
Tu parles au grand maître Hwadam.
Maître Hwadam,
qu'est-ce qui vous amène par ici ?
- Et toi...
- Qu y a t-il ?
- Tu n'es pas un homme
Un chien.
C'est toi donc le dénommé Woochi ?
Inutile d'essayer de cacher
un nom aussi célèbre.
Avoir bon caractère est essentiel
pour s'exercer l'esprit.
Pour amener la paix dans ce monde...
On m'a donné assez de leçons
aujourd'hui.
Faire preuve d'autant d'insolence
devant un maître si vertueux !
Réfléchis avant de parler.
Nous sommes des divinités taoïstes.
Tu nous regardes avec colère ?
On dirait qu il va nous mordre...
Ne te gêne pas, voyou, attaque.
Une mouche !
Malheur à toi !
Y avait pas de mouche.
Un grain de beauté.
Un vrai magicien ne trouble pas
la paix avec des singeries !
Dis-nous où est la flûte ?
Suivez-moi, c est l heure du thé.
Oh oui, du thé !
Comment a-t-il deviné
que j étais un chien ?
Ce maitre Hwadam
est impressionnant.
Il vient de s en aller,
y a une minute à peine...
La discipline du prieuré de l'Est
c est l enseignement de la magie ?
Je ne lui ai rien appris.
Il a appris ça tout seul.
Votre toit... La pluie
doit entrer à l intérieur ?
Oui et quand il fait beau,
le soleil entre aussi.
Le soleil
On dit qu'un vrai magicien
ne fait qu'un
avec la nature et les cieux.
J'aimerais devenir
la lumière de ce monde.
Je crois que Maître Hwadam
veut se procurer la flûte.
Nos trois divinités
ont fait appel à mes services
et cela me perturbe également
de me fier à d'autres magiciens.
C'est une crainte
que nous partageons tous.
Il pourrait très bien
y avoir un gobelin parmi nous
On dit que le sang
des gobelins est vert.
- Arrêtez... Que faites-vous ?
- Messieurs, je vous en prie !
Et maintenant ?
On dit que...
seules les Divinités Taoïstes
peuvent recoller la flûte.
Oui, c'est exact.
Et oui, la flûte est divisée...
Nous pouvons
nous occuper des gobelins.
Il faut le voir pour le croire...
- Voilà qui est intéressant...
- Tout à fait.
Incroyable...
La veuve dans ton rêve...
tu l as vraiment embrassée ?
- Quelle idée...
- Oui.
Vous êtes réveillée, jeune femme ?
Oui...
Chorangyi,
montre les alentours à nos invités.
Oui, tout de suite.
N'oubliez pas votre bâton.
- Tu es un brave chien.
- L'eau était très froide !
C est une bonne idée, vous croyez ?
Tu dois ramener
cette fille chez elle.
Elle mourra
si elle retourne là-bas !
Ne t en mêle plus, tu ignores
les conséquences de cet enlèvement.
Ma tête !
Que vouliez-vous dire par
"vous n'aurez que la moitié" ?
Ne me posez pas de questions
auxquelles vous avez la réponse !
Pourquoi dites-vous
que je connais la réponse ?
Hwadam aura la flûte, c est vrai !
Vous l'aurez, c est un fait...
Mais très vite
vous attendrez toute une éternité.
Si les pêchers ne fleurissent pas
sur votre côte.
Pêchers en fleurs ?
Vieille sorcière insolente !
Je suis un homme d'esprit !
Et ça vous apporte quoi l'esprit ?
Vous ne vous connaissez
même pas vous-même.
D'où vient
cette vieille femme ?
Elle était magicienne, mais
son esprit la lâche peu à peu.
Hwadam aura la flûte !
Cette bête n'est pas intelligente,
mais elle vous ramènera chez vous.
Je vous remercie de votre bonté.
Ce n'est pas la peine.
Maître.
Pourquoi dois-je m'éloigner d'elle ?
C est au cimetière
qu elle te mènera.
- Maître ?
- Concentre-toi, crétin !
Je vois que tu triches...
C est à cause
de ces satanées poutres...
Mon seigneur,
je vous remercie de tout c ur !
Oh, de rien.
On se reverra...
Mon sang, il est
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Le thé que vous avez demandé,
maître.
- Laisse-le là.
- Oui maître.
- Du sang vert.
- Je l'ai vu aussi.
Cette maison est vide.
Y-a-t-il quelqu'un ?
Quel est ce bruit ?
Ça va, ce n est rien.
Vous m'avez fait peur !
Le cheval ne fait pas des siennes ?
C'est une créature étrange.
Il ne fait que manger
et refuse d avancer.
C'est tout qu il sait faire.
Peut-être que je l'ai trop gâté.
Il n en fait qu à sa tête,
je l'ai peut-être trop gâte.
Vous êtes venu parce que vous
vous inquiétiez pour ma sécurité ?
Exact, je suis venu
pour vous protéger.
La mort ne semble pas si mal
en comparaison de ma vie ennuyeuse
J aimerais tellement
voir l océan, un jour.
- Vous voulez voir l océan ?
- Maintenant ?
Descendez, ma bien aimée.
Inspirez profondément.
Expirez.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que voici
l'océan !
C'est donc ça
l'océan ?
Mais n allez pas dans l'eau.
Mais, qu'y a-t-il après l'horizon ?
...plus d'océan, je crois.
C'est votre première fois
à vous aussi !
Disons plutôt
que quand je regarde l'océan,
je me demande comment faire le vide
qui je suis vraiment et ce que
l on doit faire de nos existences.
Oh, moi aussi !
Si je devais renaitre,
je demanderais à naître roturière.
Je danserais et je chanterais
Plus de couture ni de lecture.
Quel est ce bruit ?
Aurai-je dit la mauvaise formule ?
Vous ne devez pas aller dans
Qu est-ce... ?
Je suis un magicien.
Qu est-ce qu il est, un magicien ?
Je dirige les vents.
Je force les
Vous devriez vous éloigner un peu...
Mais il est très gentil.
C'est un vrai chenapan.
Oh, quelle horreur !
Mais revenez, ma langue est propre.
- Ça va ?
- Hé, c est moi qu elle aime.
Je connais les femmes,
c'est moi qu'elle aime.
Tu as l air bien sûr
de ton coup là !
Je l'ai ressenti quand
elle était sur mon dos.
Si je peux me permettre, madame,
c'est un chien, et pas une monture.
Mais d ici peu, je serai un homme.
Le vilain toutou...
Ça suffit, arrêtez !
Il est plus facile aux hommes
de se battre que de devenir amis ?
C est à lui qu il faut le dire,
vous savez ?
Tais-toi, tu embêtes notre amie...
Le maitre m'a dit
de ne pas utiliser la violence.
Pardonnez-moi maître.
Je vais essayer d'être gentil.
Est-ce que ça va ?
Évidemment. Faut pas s'inquiéter.
Asseyez-vous... Ça ne sera pas long.
Détends tes muscles !
Je vais te casser le bras !
J'ai dit de te détendre !
Tu me traites de chien en public ?
Ce ne sont pas des manières
Qu'est-ce qu'il...
Je l'emmène avec moi
pour divertir les foules
mais à vrai dire
il se divertit quasiment tout seul.
Je vois...
Plutôt aller en enfer
que de te rendre ça maintenant.
Tu n'es pas le seul à pouvoir faire
de la magie avec des talismans !
Vous allez bien, mon cher ?
Oui, je vais bien.
Alors tu parlais
de te vider l'esprit, hein ?
Comment se vider l'esprit
avec un imbécile comme toi ?
Qu est-ce qu y faut pas entendre,
des fois...
En fait, il n'est rien
sans ses talismans.
- Quoi, tu veux parier ?
- Bien sûr.
Très bien.
Je vais abattre cet arbre.
Il se fait tard...
On y va ?
D accord.
Qu'est-ce qui cloche chez lui ?
La moitié de flûte
vous a dévoré, Hwadam.
Maintenant, vous vous rendez compte
de qui vous êtes vraiment ?
Je suis Hwadam.
Je suis le maitre de la flute.
La flute ne répond
à aucun dieu ni maître maintenant
Ni même au grand archange.
Donnez-moi une preuve
de vos sentiments
Une preuve ?
Une preuve...
Voilà qui devrait faire l affaire,
ainsi vous devrez vous revoir.
Oh non, tout sauf,
c est une très mauvaise idée
Une preuve ?
Vous êtes Woochi, la crapule ?
C'est exact.
Woochi la crapule.
J'ai combattu non seulement le roi
mais de nombreux nobles malhonnêtes
Si cette jeune fille est triste,
je reviendrai.
De même que si on la force à lire
ou à coudre, je me verrai
dans l obligation de revenir
Ai-je été suffisamment clair ?
Oui.
Tout ira bien pour elle ?
Bien sûr.
ils ne la toucheront pas après
la crise que tu viens de piquer.
Maintenant, il faut qu'on trouve
le sabre en bronze, pas vrai ?
Comme ça tu deviendras
le plus grand magicien
- et je serai enfin un vrai homme.
- Tu as un mal de chien...
Ingrat !
Comment osez-vous tuer votre maître
et voler la flûte sacrée !
Cinq cent ans de captivité
vous apprendront !
De quoi parlez-vous, enfin ?
Tuer mon maitre ?
Je savais qu il allait
feindre l innocence...
Maintenant qu'il est coincé,
enfermons-le.
Nous, faire du mal à notre maître ?
Le maître va bien ?
Qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
Ceci appartient à mon maître...
Je crois qu il est un peu tard
pour te préoccuper de ton maître.
A l'aide, au secours !
J'ai envie de faire pipi.
Que je tire ?
Que je tire
sur l'étui de la cithare ?
Hwadam !
La flûte !
Vous étiez sensés
la garder avec vous, enfin !
Vous auriez pu arrêter
vos incantations !
Comme si j'étais le seul
à dire la formule !
Au moins les gobelins sont partis,
on a cinq cents ans de répit.
Encore cinq cents ans
pour retrouver l'archange...
Que se passera-t-il lorsque
l'archange soufflera dans la flûte ?
Le monde sera libéré !
Les gobelins iront en enfer
et l'archange tout puissant
remontera dans les cieux.
Et nous pourrons enfin
rejoindre les cieux à tout jamais.
Mais sachez que très vite,
vous attendrez toute une éternité.
Maître Hwadam.
Où allez-vous si vite ?
La fiole.
- Quand les gobelins reviendront
nous nous reverrons.
Oui ?
Vous les faites monter ?
D'accord.
Vous allez être content.
Vous avez de la visite.
Et ensuite vous m'internerez ?
Oui.
Essayez de prendre cela
pour des vacances.
J'ai beaucoup à faire.
- Puis-je l'amener, docteur ?
- Oui.
Et qu'est-ce qui vous occupe tant,
monsieur ?
J ai tant de choses à faire...
Mauvais présage !
Reposez vos mains.
Pourquoi ça ?
Ouvrez donc les yeux... Vous
ne voyez pas qu'il vous trompe ?
Je ne vous frapperai
que deux fois.
Quand il dit aller à Pusan,
c'est qu'il va voir l'autre femme.
La question est :
pourquoi votre mari vous trompe ?
Vous êtes folle à lier.
Le chat mort sur vos épaules
effraie les hommes !
Un chat, où ça ?
Le chat qui vit sur vos épaules !
Trop de péchés
dans votre vie antérieure
Vous avez tué l'empereur
en empoisonnant son café !
Ne refais plus jamais de café.
Suivante.
- Combien je vous dois ?
- On ne parle pas d argent !
Laissez quelques obscènes billets
sur la table.
Quoi ?
Derrière vous...
Partez !
Bonjour ?
Doux jésus !
Comment ça « cassée » ?
Si seulement maître Hwadam était là.
Ça fait des années
qu'on ne l'a pas vu.
Aux dernières nouvelles,
il était sur le Mont Jiri.
On peut le faire nous même.
On ne peut pas les attraper
nous-mêmes !
Bon sang, mais pourquoi pas ?
Donc ce serait deux gobelins ?
Ils se sont glissés
dans des corps humains.
Ils ont abandonné leur peau.
Je ne vous avais pas dit
que je les avais trouvées ?
Et où les avez-vous trouvées
ces peaux ?
En face de l'hôpital.
De l'hôpital ?
Ouais.
Il vous en aura fallu du temps,
bande de divinités grotesques.
Pourquoi avez-vous mis
autant de temps ?
Qu'on se dépêche ou non,
on se fait toujours hurler dessus.
Qu'avez-vous fait des fioles ?
Qui, moi, rien du tout.
- Là est tout le problème !
- Pourquoi serait-ce un problème ?
Vous avez acheté une voiture ?
Qu'en est-il de la vie d'ascète
et du refus du monde matériel ?
C'est une question de critères !
On n'a pas les mêmes critères.
On a besoin d un plan,
concentrez-vous !
Hwadam est parti, on doit demander
de l aide à quelqu'un d'autre.
Quelqu'un d'autre ? Qui ?
Exact !
Hors de question !
Je ne veux rien savoir !
On visite le temple
pour rencontrer Bouddha
pas les moines qui y vivent.
Cet imbécile n'est pas Bouddha.
Il a tué le maitre !
Ne parlons plus de ça.
Ni du fait qu'on n'ait
pas encore trouvé Hwadam.
« Attrapez les gobelins !
Et on vous libérera ! »
On va lui acheter à boire,
le gratter là où ça le démange
Le libérer ?
- Et on l'enfermera à nouveau...
- Bien sûr.
Nous ne pouvons pas mentir...
Des divinités comme nous
devraient tenir leur parole.
Donne-lui un titre de noblesse.
Titre de noblesse, mes fesses...
Allez.
Vous avez apporté la Bible ?
Je crois que je l ai oubliée.
On essaie encore ?
Allons-y !
Ça marche ?
Woochi, mon seigneur !
Vous devez être désorienté
après ces cinq cent ans de sommeil !
Vous souvenez-vous de nous ?
De l'eau.
À boire. Donnez-lui à boire !
Les gobelins sont revenus, seigneur.
Les cieux nous ont ordonné
de libérer le magicien Woochi
afin qu'il les capture !
Vous serez libre
et vous deviendrez célèbre
Pourquoi le ferais-je ?
Pourquoi ?
Donc Woochi la crap
incroyablement puissant...
Un héros !
Le peuple l adore !
Incroyablement puissant...
- Un magicien distingué ?
- Quoi ?
Cela va de soi !
Le plus stylé des magiciens !
Téméraire, élégant...
Les caractéristiques mêmes
de la vertu !
Attrapez les gobelins... et vous
serez enfin de cette trempe !
- J'en n'ai pas envie.
- Pas envie ?
Pourquoi me donner tant de peine,
alors que je suis déjà libre ?
Débrouillez-vous tous seuls...
On fait pas le poids !
Hors de question !
« Hors de question » ?
Et pourquoi devrais-je
le faire au juste ?
Oui, pourquoi lui ?
Parce que nous allons
lui donner un titre.
Oui ! Un titre de noblesse !
Un titre ?
Haut magicien.
Du prieuré Royal.
Ahhh !
Du prieuré Royal ?
Mais je dois encore trouver
le sabre en bronze.
Suis-je encore à la hauteur
d'un tel titre ?
Plus qu'à la hauteur !
Alors, on y va, maître ?
Où est Hwadam ?
Il est mort, il y a des années.
Quelqu'un vient.
Il y a une autre sortie,
j imagine...
Pour quoi faire ?
D'abord, on doit s'enfuir.
Allons, battez vous !
Je n'ai aucun talisman.
Allons chercher la voiture !
- Je le savais !
- Mails la porte est là !
Il est là !
Et au fait...
Où sont les chaînes
que j avais aux pieds ?
Si vous refusez de les voir,
vous ne les verrez pas !
Vous ne les voyez pas,
mais elles sont toujours là !
- Cette caisse est froide !
- C'est une sorte de monture.
Il a l air complètement sonné,
poussez-le à l'intérieur.
Et où sont vos talismans ?
- Chorangyi les a.
- Chorangyi ?
Rattrapez-le.
- Quoi ?
- Montez.
- Où on va ?
- Et Chorangyi !
- Qui est Chorangyi ?
- Ce chien pouilleux !
L estampe de Chorangyi.
- L estampe de Chorangyi ?
- Oui.
- Je l'ai jetée en déménageant.
- Quoi ?
Ouais, c'est moi.
Tu te souviens des tableaux
que je t'ai donnés ?
Pas le joli tableau, celui où il y a
un chien et une sorte d énergumène.
- Je l'ai vendu.
- Tu l'as vendu ?
Alors écoute, tu dois le récupérer.
C est incroyable
comme ce pays a changé !
Mais les hommes, eux,
ne changent pas.
La mort peut venir
les chercher à tout moment
mais regardez ces imbéciles !
Ils gâchent leur vie
en assouvissant leurs désirs
au lieu de chercher
l'élévation spirituelle.
Namas Avalokitesvara Bodhisattva...
Que font les hommes pour gagner
le c ur des femmes ?
Ils doivent s agenouiller
pour les séduire...
S'agenouiller ?
Oui.
- Si elle est du style James Bond.
- James Bond ? C est ça !
Tout cela dévie les gens
de la spiritualité
On se rend vite compte qu elles
ne servent qu à s attirer des ennuis
Il est triste qu une divinité
comme vous tombe dans le panneau.
Regarde devant toi !
- Je sais où il se trouve.
- Tu as l adresse ?
109 district Dapsip.
On sait où il se trouve ?
- Mais c'est fermé.
- On fait quoi maintenant ?
On cambriole !
Qu'est-ce qu'elles ont ces filles ?
Elles annoncent l'ouverture
d'une nouvelle discothèque.
Une maison close ?
Une taverne enfumée,
où la musique rend sourd.
Le roi de cette terre
est malade lui aussi.
Il n'y a plus de roi
depuis longtemps !
C'est la vérité.
Bien des choses
se sont produites au cours de...
A droite !
Regardez devant vous !
Mais qu'est ce que c'est ?
Ouvrez les yeux !
Tout va bien !
On ne peut pas mourir !
Par contre, Woochi...
- Est-ce que ça va ?
- Chut.
Je fais le vide.
Hé, regardez ça,
ça a marché !
- D'accord seigneur.
- Attention devant !
Seigneur Woochi !
- Plus vite, plus vite !
- D'accord.
- Non, ralentissez.
- Ralentissez.
Accélérez !
Ralentissez !
C'était vraiment une mauvaise idée !
Donnez-moi votre main !
- Il est monté ?
- Oui !
- Derrière nous !
- Où ça ?
Roulez plus vite !
Attention !
Le bus !
- La troisième voie !
- D'accord !
- Faut tourner à droite !
- Je mets mon clignotant.
Mais tournez à droite !
Ça fonctionne !
Freinez !
Numéro 109.
Venez, Monseigneur.
Numéro 109...
- Numéro 109.
- C'est par là.
Par ici !
On arrive, Chorangyi.
- Par là !
- On l'a trouvé !
Où est Woochi ?
Il était là.
Allez par là, nous le chercherons
de l autre côté !
Maître !
Maître ?
Je n ai rien fait,
arrêtez de me suivre !
Je l'ai trouvé.
Vous l'avez trouvé ?
Oui je l'ai !
La formule magique.
Il faut que l on soit
tous les trois !
Allô ?
- On doit prononcer la formule.
- Au téléphone ?
Je crois que je me suis
brisé le dos !
C est intéressant.
Tous en c ur !
Un deux trois !
Satanée fumée !
- Chorangyi.
- Où sont les talismans ?
Woochi !
Ça en fait un bail.
Les jolis talismans !
Une envie pressante !
Chorangyi !
Mais j'ai envie de faire pipi.
Rien de cassé ?
Jolie musique.
Il est temps que je passe
à la vitesse supérieure !
- Oh, Woochi !
- Continuez !
Vous vous débrouillez bien,
maître !
Faites attention, maître !
Woochi !
Est-ce que ça va ?
- Besoin d'aide ?
- Je vais me débrouiller.
Maintenant, je vais vraiment passer
à la vitesse supérieure.
Il était temps !
Il fait quoi celui-là ?
Non, retourne-toi.
Derrière-toi.
C'est ça.
- De l'autre côté.
- Retourne-toi, crétin !
- Allez... Suis-les !
- Allez !
Lequel d'entre vous
est le vrai Woochi ?
Il va falloir que je m'en mêle,
comme d'habitude.
Venez, on va rigoler.
C est parti !
Je fonce dans le tas !
Où je peux trouver un bâton ?
- Attention !
- Oh là là !
Baisse-toi !
Vous avez vu ?
Bien.
Enfermons les gobelins.
Woochi et Chorangyi aussi.
- Maître Woochi !
- Quel talent !
Allez enfermer les gobelins.
On a réussi !
On ? J'ai réussi.
Ça recommence ?
J'ai brisé le poignet de la fille.
- Vous l'avez entendue crier !
- Maître !
- Le gobelin n'est plus là !
- Quoi ?
Il est parti.
Comme je l'avais prévu.
Hé ! Où tu vas ?
Woochi !
C'était quoi ?
- Tu as renversé quelqu'un ?
- Oui...
Non. Non.
On a besoin de Woochi !
Que fait cet homme déguisé
au beau milieu de la route ?
Vous avez raison, c'est un fou.
Il est mort, vous croyez ?
N'ouvre pas la porte.
Autant ne pas sortir
dans une situation pareille.
- Il se relève !
- Oh j y crois pas !
- Donne-moi ta carte.
- Amène-le à l'hôpital.
Est-ce que ça va ?
Faites-vous d'abord soigner
puis appelez ce numéro.
Je connais ces yeux...
Mais qui êtes vous ?
Ils portent tout l'océan en eux.
Vous êtes ivre ?
Woochi !
Un autre fou !
Allez à l'hôpital.
C'est elle !
Inutile de me cacher,
ils m ont reconnu ! Oui, c est moi.
Mais qu'est-ce que...
N'entrez pas dans la voiture.
Je vous signerai un autographe.
Maître, il ne faut pas
harceler les gens.
- Reculez, reculez.
- Je suis désolé. Je ferme...
- Je vous connais ?
- Oui, c'est moi.
Démarre !
La veuve !
Hé, regarde-moi,
est-ce que tu vois l océan
dans mon visage, toi ?
Il essayait sans doute
d'être gentil.
Encore un frapadingue
Donne-moi mon chapeau.
Oui.
J ai pas envie de tourner
aujourd'hui.
Quel monde étrange.
Hé.
Pourquoi Hwadam a-t-il
tué notre maitre ?
Il doit être en train
de préparer quelque chose.
- Tu crois qu'il est là, lui aussi ?
- Il n'est plus là.
C'est pour cela
qu'ils sont venus me chercher.
Je vois que tu deviens intelligent.
Je peux pas aller contre ma nature.
Une seconde...
Du sang vert !
Ça sent bon.
Pourquoi il est couché par terre ?
Il a besoin d'aide.
Maître, pas maintenant.
Aie foi en notre Seigneur.
Par là, maître.
Sans Roi, qui va nourrir le peuple ?
- Pas de roi ?
- Des hommes d'affaires
Les souverains des temps modernes.
Ils ont construit
tous ces hauts édifices.
Ne te moque pas de moi.
Les marchands sont des fanatiques
corrompus par nature.
Et toi tu dis qu'ils donnent
à manger au peuple ?
Un tel pays est directement voué
à sa perte.
Qu est-ce que c est, de l'alcool ?
C'est pour cela
qu'un homme important
est venu nous sauver de nos péchés.
Je suis un modèle à suivre ?
Non, je parle de Jésus Christ
il nous protège avec une puissance
inimaginable et inégalée.
Alors pourquoi n as-tu pas demandé
à Jésus de te venir en aide ?
Il doit être occupé.
C'est le sang du Christ,
le sang du Christ !
C'est le sang de quelqu'un ?
C'est très bon, très savoureux.
- Cette odeur, Maître !
- Il est pas bon ce sang ?
Par là mon seigneur.
Les traces de sang vert vont par là.
- J'étais si triste
- Et me voici si joyeux maintenant.
- J'en veux !
- Par là.
- Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
C'est aussi une sorte de monture.
C'est quoi cet endroit ?
Un lieu de débauche, Monseigneur.
Je suis d'accord avec vous.
Sortez !
Viens.
Viens, on sort.
Retourne en enfer.
Excellent travail !
Je pense avoir trouvé
un moyen de la revoir...
Explosifs !
Traître !
Je l ai fait pour le pays.
Pour le pays...
Vous êtes un traître
et vous le payerez !
Vous deviez monter
dans le train suivant.
- J'ai perdu mon billet.
C est moi que vous venez de perdre !
Vous disiez m'aimer.
Était-ce un mensonge ?
Je me suis mentie à moi même.
Au revoir, mon amour.
Mais tu fais quoi, là ?
Tire !
C est fini... Au revoir.
Coupez !
Il gèle, ici !
- J'ai manqué mon coup. C'est nul !
- C'était génial !
Ça sent l'Oscar !
C est sur elle qu on devrait tirer.
Tout était hors champ.
Tu dois suivre les marques au sol.
Je sais.
Ces chaussures...
Elles font mal !
Je vais avoir des d'ampoules !
- Apporte-moi l'autre paire.
- Tout de suite !
Vous devez chanter comme Audrey
- et courir comme Marilyn.
- Et quand je tire ?
Tirez comme...
C'est si difficile ?
Et ça, c'est quoi ?
Mes chaussures !
J'arrive !
- Chaussures !
- J arrive !
Tirez comme Angelina Jolie.
Si vous voulez que je tire
comme elle, payez moi comme elle.
Je sais que vous y êtes pour rien !
Ces chaussures font perdre du temps
à tout le monde.
Elles sont trop petites.
Trouves-en de plus grandes
au lieu de me forcer à y entrer !
Qu'est-ce qu'elle fait ?
Regardez, elle ne sait même pas
distinguer la droite et la gauche !
Que je suis bête...
Ne vous appuyez pas !
Vous semblez oubliez ces chaînes
que vous avez aux pieds.
Comment ça ?
Où que vous alliez,
nous pouvons vous ramener à nous.
Allez chercher
le directeur artistique !
Qu'est-ce que tu fais ?
J'ai vu quelqu'un ici...
Et il s'est fait écraser !
Ces chaussures vont me tuer.
Cette fois, ça va ?
Une taille au-dessus.
D'accord.
Pour l'amour du ciel,
plus vite, plus vite, plus vite !
J y suis, une minute...
Je reviens.
Vous risquez d avoir
du mal à les enlever !
Vous devrez retirer ces chaînes
quand je vous livrerai ces gobelins.
Bien sûr !
T as appris où à danser, toi ?
Dans les montagnes !
Tu veux qu'on sorte ensemble,
beau gosse ?
Quoi ?
Je savais que ce Woochi allait
nous donner du fil à retordre.
Où en sont les choses ?
Il l'a attrapé ?
Oui, ça y est.
Et dites-lui de faire attention
à la fiole.
Avec ce nigaud,
on peut s attendre à tout...
On a besoin de la flûte !
Maître,
nous avons besoin de la flûte...
- C'est fatigant tout ça !
- Quel drôle d estampe !
N'y allez pas !
Maître ?
Attendez, je crois
que c'est par là.
Et qu en savez vous ?
Mon sixième sens !
On va se fier à votre sens ?
C'est par là.
Et comment le savez-vous ?
Ça fait un siècle
que je prévois l'avenir.
Il y a des vibrations étranges,
comme dans une prison souterraine.
Attendez-moi, s il vous plait !
Non !
Quelle idée !
Disparaître du plateau
pour aller faire une sieste.
Regarde !
Regarde mon épiderme !
Tu stresses ma peau.
Elle devient flasque !
C'est vrai.
Pardon ?
C est faux...
Votre teint est superbe !
Tais-toi... Va me chercher un café,
noir et serré.
Oui, un café noir et serré.
Bon travail, monsieur.
Avec elle, c était pas gagné.
Attends, je vais trouver ta photo.
La voilà !
C'est ta photo, tu vois ?
Elle doit faire une fixation
sur toi.
Ouais...
Mes affaires !
Elle flirte
avec tout ce qui se bouge.
Je t'ai entendu demander
une audition au réalisateur.
Je l ai fait par politesse.
Par politesse ?
Jusqu'où iras-tu par politesse ?
Voilà votre café.
J'en ai déjà un.
Tu n as qu à le boire.
D'accord.
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Belle photo.
On dirait une station balnéaire.
J'irai là-bas un jour ou l autre.
In-kyung.
Pourquoi on n'irait pas
là-bas tous les deux ?
- Ça te dirait ?
- Bien sûr.
Un commentaire, monsieur ?
Nous espérons que cette enquête
lavera le congrès de soupçons
ainsi que les directeurs
de collections d'art
des grandes entreprises.
On dit que le verdict
a déjà été acheté.
C'est faux.
Vous êtes sûr qu'il ne s'agit pas
d'une agitation inutile ?
Je vous assure,
ce n'est pas le cas.
T'as vu ça ?
J'ai vu.
Le sabre doit se trouver
dans l une de ces caisses !
- On doit y aller ?
- Et comment !
Mais comment a-t-il voyagé
du manoir des ducs jusqu'ici ?
Hé !
Comment vous êtes entrés ?
Je suis venu chercher
le sabre de bronze.
Vous êtes frères ?
Qui est l'ainé ?
Ton pelage est plus soyeux !
Va jouer avec ton frère,
nous on a des choses à faire.
Pourquoi ils ont
des cordes autour du cou ?
Il ne manque pas de courage.
Je vais te coller une raclée.
Il peut pas regarder devant lui,
l imbécile ?
Ça me dépasse.
Veuillez fournir
votre code d'identification.
Ce gentilhomme s'appelle Woochi.
Veuillez fournir
votre code d'identification.
Je crois que cette fille
ne te connaît pas.
Je dois lui dire d'où tu viens ?
Ce que tu veux.
Un magicien très renommé
de Pyongyang.
Maître.
Élève du maître du prieuré de l'Est
spécialiste de la magie ancestrale.
La noble personne qui s'adresse
à vous n est autre que Woochi.
Veuillez fournir
votre code d'identification.
Ça suffit, espèce d'idiote !
Laisse-moi faire.
Sorcière infatigable !
Montre-toi sorcière maléfique !
Voyons maintenant
si je flaire du bronze.
Je savais bien
que ça sentait la pomme.
Très beau tableau.
Cette fois, on l'attrape et
on l'enferme pendant sept siècles.
Il n'y aura plus d'humains
d ici sept siècles.
Vous voulez entendre
quelque chose de drôle ?
J'ai vu un médecin y a une semaine.
Vous savez ce qu'il a dit ?
D'arrêter de fumer immédiatement.
Parce que ça provoque des maladies.
Des maladies !
On aura tout entendu !
Quel idiot.
Du sang...
Il me rappelle quelqu'un...
Appelez Woochi.
Entendu.
Le téléphone !
Décrochez le téléphone !
Vous pourriez
me laisser me reposer.
Appelez Woochi !
Appelez-le !
Maître Woochi !
Je l'ai trouvé.
Maintenant on a tout.
Commencez les incantations !
Vous m'entendez ?
Les incantations ! D accord !
Ramenez-moi avec lui !
Tu es sûr que c est le bon sabre ?
Allez-y !
T'es sûr que c'est
le grand sabre en bronze ?
Il est peut-être rouillé.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
Chorangyi !
Qu'est-ce que vous faites là ?
Remonte-nous !
Qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
Il ne sait pas nager.
Alors,
qu est-ce qu il fait dans l eau ?
Vous l'avez attrapé ?
Woochi !
Est-ce que ça va, maître ?
Ça va.
Excellent travail.
Tu nages de mieux en mieux !
- Excellent travail.
- Bon boulot !
Seigneur Woochi, s'il vous plait,
un instant.
Nous allons vous faire
un grand cadeau.
Débarrassons-nous de celui-là
d'abord. Prenez la fiole.
Ils s'enfuient.
Ils n iront pas bien loin.
Débarrassons-nous de lui.
Je commence à en avoir marre !
- Et de ces chaînes !
- Si tu y penses, elles seront là.
Pourquoi y penser alors ?
Mais comment ne pas y penser ?
Bon sang, je ne veux pas
qu on me coupe la patte.
On peut utiliser tes talismans !
Excellent. Maintenant,
au tour de Woochi.
- Chorangyi.
- Oui ?
Lève la jambe.
- Laissons tomber.
- Pourquoi ?
Une promesse est une promesse.
Nous devons nous débarrasser de lui.
Tout doux, hein ?
Ça a marché.
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Comment a-t-il enlevé ses chaînes ?
C est enfin fini.
Pas encore, on doit l'enfermer.
Et avec quels pouvoirs ?
Mon Père ! Pouvez-vous
écouter ma confession ?
Je suis un peu occupé.
Si c'est un petit péché,
revenez demain.
C'est un très gros péché.
Il ne doit pas être
aussi gros que ça.
Vous pouvez tout confesser
à notre seigneur.
Il doit être débordé.
C est probable, oui.
Y a-t-il réellement un chat mort
sur mes épaules ?
Qui vous a dit une chose pareille ?
Quelqu'un,
il y a quelques jours à peine.
Vous pourriez vérifier ?
Tiens donc. Il y a deux chats.
Tout le monde porte
ses péchés antérieurs avec soi.
La beauté de la vie, c'est que
les bonnes actions effacent...
Une minute, mon enfant.
Sortez de là, faites vite.
Revenez là, attendez !
- Qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
- Les fioles !
- Quoi ?
- Elles vibrent !
Quoi ?
Regardez !
Comment sont-ils sortis
des fioles ?
Maître Hwadam !
Ce sont peut-être
des créatures ingénieuses
mais ce ne sont pas
des adversaires pour moi.
Comment allez-vous ?
- Ça fait longtemps, messieurs.
- Plus puissant que jamais !
Maintenant que vous êtes de retour,
plus besoin de Woochi...
Vous avez rappelé cet imbécile ?
C est sa faute... Il a insisté
Je n'étais pas tout seul ! Et vous
n'avez pas surveillé les fioles ?
Pourquoi supposez-vous
que les fioles sont cassées ?
Comme Maître Hwadam
vient de le dire
si les gobelins sont venus en
sachant que nous appellerions Woochi
alors c'est Woochi
qui contrôle les gobelins.
- Comment ?
- Il a l'autre moitié de la flûte.
C'est vrai.
Je savais que je ne pouvais pas
lui faire confiance.
Woochi a attrapé les gobelins !
C'est moi
qui ai attrapé ces gobelins.
C'est vrai.
Et c'est à moi de récupérer
la moitié que ce vaurien m'a volé.
Quand vous l'aurez,
réparez la flûte
et gardez-la en lieu sûr.
Mais vous ne savez pas
où se trouve Woochi.
Oui, c est ça. C'est ça.
Parfait !
Une dernière.
C'est bon ?
Vous devez enfiler ça maintenant.
- On est où ?
- En Thaïlande.
Les poses !
Oui, les poses.
En voilà une
Autre pose
Et la dernière.
La troisième est grotesque.
- La deux est la plus facile.
- Ouais.
Oh, c'est bizarre ça.
Bon sang !
- Vous avez rien entendu ?
- Non.
C'est qui ces deux là ?
Qu est-ce que vous...
Sang-ho, viens m'aider !
Ne touchez pas à ça !
S'il vous plait, sortez !
Allez !
- Dehors !
- D'accord, je m en vais...
Mais vous...
Vous avez perdu du poids.
Qui êtes-vous ?
C'est moi, Chorangyi !
Vous êtes déjà monté sur mon dos.
Ah bon ?
Je vous ai même
léché les mains comme ça !
Pourquoi ?
Parce qu'à l'époque
j'étais un cheval.
- Pardon ?
- Mais en fait, je suis un chien.
- Chien ?
- Mais je vais devenir un humain.
Parce que Woochi est
le plus grand magicien au monde !
Toutes ces années
et vous n'avez pas pris une ride !
Ouais !
Quel plaisir de vous voir !
Qui êtes-vous à la fin ?
Renversé par une voiture, écrasé
par un mur et vous revoilà.
Est-ce que vous êtes
en train de me suivre ?
Je vous l avais promis :
je veillerai sur vous.
Car celui qui est face à vous...
- n est autre que le grand Woo...
- Promis à qui ?
À vous.
Vous devez vous tromper
de personne...
Non, c'est bien vous.
Qu'est-ce que vous me voulez ?
Vous offrir toute la panoplie.
Je connais vos goûts...
Vous avez bu ou quoi ?
Je déteste les diseurs
de bonne aventure.
On m'a dit que je conduirais
un remorqueur lors d une tempête.
Vous détestez la lecture.
Oui.
Vous détestez coudre.
C'est bien vrai.
Je tiens en horreur
le fil et les aiguilles.
Vous êtes un magicien.
Je ne suis pas un magicien
comme les autres.
Quel genre de magicien êtes-vous ?
Ce genre de magicien...
Pardon ?
Et voilà qui répond
à votre question !
Mais comment...
Oh !
C'est bien ma veine.
Allô ?
En face de votre poster ?
J'ai été enlevée !
Vous n'êtes pas dans votre loge ?
C est ce gugusse
qu on a renversé en voiture
Attends.
J'ai un appel en attente.
Pourquoi t'as pas décroché ?
Où suis-je ?
Les enfants... où sommes-nous ?
Attends, ces gamins
me regardent bizarrement !
Je ne suis pas cette actrice !
Je vous en prie !
On veut juste un autographe.
Mon grand frère est policier !
Vous lui avez fait quelque chose ?
Oui.
Pourquoi ?
- Parce que...
- In-kyung a été enlevée !
Alors, elle est vraiment partie.
- On y va, In-kyung !
- J'arrive.
On se voit tout à l heure.
Vas-y, raconte,
qu'est-ce qu'elle a dit ?
Arobase...
- Yahoo ? point...
- Point ?
- Com ?
Ils sont fous ces humains.
Je t'amène une dernière fois
avant de devenir un être humain.
- La dernière fois ?
- Oui.
Dernière fois que quoi ?
Je t'amène avant d'être un humain.
Tu es un grand magicien maintenant,
avec le miroir et le sabre et tout.
Donc, il est temps pour moi
de devenir un humain, non ?
Ce ne sont
que des symboles, enfin !
Les symboles d'un grand magicien.
Des symboles ?
C est fatigant à la longue.
Je ne serais pas un humain
si je suivais un menteur comme toi !
Je vais demander à Hwadam
de me transformer.
Où est Hwadam ?
Alors maintenant tu écoutes
ce que j'ai à dire ?
Tu as vu Hwadam ?
Bien sûr.
Où ça ?
Dans l'atelier quand on cherchait
le sabre de bronze.
J ai vu son emblème...
Tu vois ce que je veux dire ?
Et tu vas où maintenant ?
Je vais trouver Hwadam.
Quel âge as-tu ?
J ai 16 ans.
Une vie plus longue
serait tout aussi vide.
Le type qui a lancé le mandat
est un ancien camarade de classe
Il sait qu'il n'y a rien chez moi
mais c'est juste une formalité.
Mais merci encore
de m'avoir prévenu.
J'ai déplacé ce bureau
il y a quelques mois.
Oui, entendu, au revoir...
À l'ancien bureau,
monsieur le député ?
Faites vite.
Je n'ai jamais vu un homme élu
par le peuple réellement l'aider...
Comment êtes-vous entré ?
Vous êtes d un groupe de citoyens ?
Vous connaissez celui
qui utilise cet emblème ?
Vous savez qui je suis ?
Un député à son troisième mandat !
Je vous repose la question.
Où est-il ?
Il doit être dans le coin,
allez savoir...
Dans le coin ? Où ça ?
Si vous le voulez vraiment,
il viendra à vous un de ces jours.
Je devrais vous écorcher vif
pour vous donner une bonne leçon
mais je suis trop occupé,
vous avez de la chance.
- Salut ?
- Quoi ?
Tu m'as vu !
Je passais dans le coin.
Quelle vie de chien.
Jack ! On n'a plus de gaz !
Gaz ?
Elle veut du feu.
Tu peux le faire.
Le chauffe-plat est cassé.
Il est cassé ?
Ça m'étonne pas.
C'est pour ça
que la magie n y faisait rien !
Où te sauvais-tu comme ça ?
J'avais juste besoin d'air frais.
Ça en faisait un bail !
Aurais-tu peur de la mort ?
Pas vraiment de la mort,
mais plutôt d'être
en train de mourir.
Ça nous ramène
à des siècles en arrière.
C'est vrai !
Vous vous en souvenez ?
Vous m aviez jeté dans l'eau.
C est le genre de chose
qui unit les gens !
Je peux te transformer en humain.
Humain ?
Ou ?
Ou je peux faire brûler tes organes
en claquant des doigts.
Il reste combien de talismans
à Woochi ?
Pourquoi ?
Vous voulez
que je vous donne ses talismans ?
Sans eux, il est perdu...
Tu ne veux pas être humain ?
- Oh si !
- Oui.
Humain...
Quel enfer !
Tu te souviens du dingue ?
Ce fou m a enlevé !
J'arrive pas à expliquer
comment je suis arrivée ici.
Pourquoi tu me regardes
comme ça, toi ?
Hein ?
Tu ne me crois pas ?
Oh si... je vous crois.
Non. Tu ne me crois pas.
Personne ne me croit !
Je vais le dire à Honeybuns !
- Tu m'as fait couler un bain ?
- Oui.
Alors va-t-en.
- Je peux y aller aussi ?
- Reste jusqu'à qu'il arrive.
Honeypoo, c'est moi.
Miaou.
Miaou...
Amène-moi Woochi.
Pourquoi ?
Pour que je récupère la flûte
et que je vous libère tous.
Pourquoi je ne peux pas travailler
avec un réalisateur normal ?
Il se comporte
comme s'il allait à Cannes !
Attends une minute.
Je te rappelle tout de suite.
Ki-chul, éteins ça, allez !
C est pas vrai.
Ki-chul !
Ki-chul ?
Arrête tes âneries. J ai peur.
Attaquée, mon il !
Elle a dû glisser
dans sa baignoire.
Tu as vu comme elle marche !
Elle allait se casser un truc !
N'y va même pas. Ce rôle
n'est pas fait pour tout le monde.
Elle doit être belle.
Avoir de l'assurance.
Se déplacer avec grâce et élégance.
Avoir du feu dans les yeux...
Je dois te laisser.
Je n'avais pas fait attention
à tes yeux avant.
Ils ont quelque chose de spécial.
L'océan ?
L'océan.
C'est ça, l'océan !
On doit faire un bout d essai !
Vous voudriez aussi
que je prenne la pose.
- Comme ça ?
- Exact !
Allons prendre un verre
quelque part.
Je vais chercher l'addition.
Où est-elle passée ?
Woochi !
Woochi ?
On a attrapé deux gobelins,
n'est-ce pas ?
Oui, toi et moi, ensemble.
Pourtant, il en reste
encore un en liberté.
Où ça ?
- Pas très loin.
- Pas très loin ?
Ce gobelin me conduira à Hwadam.
Pourquoi tu m'appelais au fait ?
Tu ne voulais plus me voir.
C'est faux, arrête !
Woochi, prends-moi dans tes bras !
Le maître disait que tous les liens
étaient faits de douleur.
Chut !
Fais bien attention.
Toi aussi !
Hé !
Tu va sortir de la route !
Alors, c est fait ?
Oui c'est fait.
Il doit en avoir encore un ou deux.
Tu vas trahir ton meilleur ami.
Tu deviens humain.
Donc, je suis en train
de devenir humain ?
Comment veux-tu qu un chien
devienne un homme ?
Pourquoi me suis-tu, Woochi ?
Tu trouves que j ai changé un peu ?
Où est Hwadam ?
C'est tout ce que tu veux savoir ?
On dit que la beauté
est souvent envenimée.
Et qu appelles-tu la beauté ?
Raconte-moi.
Des yeux plus purs
que ne l est l'océan.
L arrête du nez
comme une majestueuse montagne.
Est-ce que tu oublies
de parler de mes lèvres ?
Qu'est-ce que vous dites ?
J'ai trahi mon meilleur ami !
J ai fait ce que vous
m aviez demandé !
Tu es là pour voir mourir
ton cher ami.
Mourir ?
Non, c'est pas possible !
Woochi !
Ne t'approche pas, Woochi !
Qu'est-ce que tu fais là, toi ?
Hwadam est là...
J'ai attendu très longtemps...
Ton arrogance a fini
par t'amener jusqu'ici.
Je ne peux pas ignorer mon talent.
Même sans tes précieux talismans ?
Qu'es-ce que je dois faire ?
Woochi ! Attention !
C'est une belle nuit pour mourir.
Pourquoi dois-je
m'éloigner d'elle ?
C est au cimetière
qu elle te mènera.
Alors qu elle me mène
au cimetière.
Tu as peur de mourir ?
Il te reste un encore un talisman !
Je vais t'aider !
Terrasse-le
avec le dernier talisman !
Un seul talisman
ne servira pas à grand chose.
M as-tu conduit
jusqu au cimetière ?
Le dernier talisman, idiot !
Suis-je en train de rêver ?
La vie n'est qu'un rêve.
Le gentilhomme qui est face à vous
n est autre que Woochi.
Il ne craint pas la mort.
Cette crapule a failli
nous faire perdre ceci.
Ça ne sera pas très long.
La flûte est enfin recollée.
Chorangyi, vilain chien !
Espèce d'abruti !
Regardez son éventail !
C'est Hwadam qui a tué
notre maître, bande d'idiots !
Maître Hwadam ne ferait pas ça...
Cet idiot délire...
Il me reste un dernier talisman,
je l'avais caché.
Moi, Chorangyi, préfère mourir
en tant que chien
que de devenir
un humain répugnant !
Feu !
Qu'est-ce qui m'arrive ?
Pourquoi je dessine
ce que j'ai déjà en tête ?
Est-ce que tu vas bien ?
Il est temps de passer
à la vitesse supérieure !
Woochi a pris la flûte !
Mon esprit n'est pas encore vide.
Où est-ce que tu vas ?
Dans mon endroit préféré.
Attention !
La porte se referme !
Où sommes-nous ?
Je suis coincé.
Je suis coincé !
Tirez-moi.
Protège la fille.
D'accord, pas de problème.
Mon cou !
Qui est cette femme ?
- La veuve.
- La veuve ?
D'il y a cinq siècles.
Cinq siècles ?
Est-ce qu'elle pourrait être...
Non, seigneur Woochi !
N allez pas par là !
Au feu ! Au feu !
Attendez-moi !
Tirez !
Voilà comment invoquer
correctement les vents.
L'un d'eux n'est pas réel.
Celui-là est faux !
Tu es un meilleur adversaire
que ton maître.
Et toi, tu repères bien mieux
le talent.
Les meilleurs invités savent
quand ils doivent partir.
Maître !
Maître Woochi !
Woochi !
Est-ce que ça va ?
C'est un gobelin aussi ?
Cette femme est...
Je ne le crois pas.
Qui êtes vous ?
Venez avec nous,
mon enfant !
Ma côte.
Le pêcher est en fleurs ?
Vous êtes folle !
Tais-toi !
Elle pourrait être l'archange...
Regardez bien.
Cette femme, c'est l'archange ?
C'est qui ça ?
Elle ne se souvient pas de nous.
Il fuit la solitude du taoïste
et rêve de réussite confucéenne
pauvre de lui...
En même temps, il veut connaître
la réalité des choses
Une façon comme une autre de tester
l étendue de ses connaissances.
Qu'est-ce que tu racontes ?
Maître.
Maître, vous allez bien ?
Sa sottise m'ahurit...
Il doit avoir de la fièvre, maître.
Tu as combattu Hwadam avec moi.
Quoi ?
- Et tu m'as même trahi.
- Et il n'a pas encore dessaoulé.
Je vous envoie en mission
et vous allez dans un palace
et vous osez ridiculiser le roi !
- Vous vous battez...
- Se battre contre des gobelins...
...et vous enlevez une veuve...
Se battre contre des gobelins
et venger ma mort en rêve.
Et même combattre Hwadam.
Toutes ces choses
t'ont-elles vidé l'esprit ?
Il avait déjà la tête vide !
Est-ce la réalité ?
Je suis venu te sermonner dans
un rêve pour t'éclaircir les idées.
- Maître.
- Bois ton thé.
Alors cette fille...
Ramène-la chez elle.
Ne t en mêle plus...
Oui, d'accord...
Voilà.
Maître.
Quand vous avez écrit
Tire sur l'étui de la cithare ...
Qu'est-ce que tu dis ?
Bois ton thé, il va refroidir.
Allez...
Qu'est-ce que tu fais enfin ?
Le maître avait tout vu
jusqu'à cet instant.
Maître !
Vous allez bien ?
On s'occupe de cette crapule ?
Nous avions foi en vous
depuis le début...
Maître.
Bande de Divinités grotesques.
Je vais y aller moi-même.
Woochi !
J'ai entendu dire quelque part...
que les vrais gentlemen
ne sont pas rancuniers.
Bien.
Je vais faire de toi un humain.
Ah oui ?
Je vais d'abord te révéler
ta véritable identité.
Je sais, je suis un chien crétin.
Oui, mais attends...
Tu es une chienne...
Ah oui ?
Oui.
Comment
Comment ça une chienne ?
Les hommes et les animaux
ont toujours vécu en harmonie.
Ça c'est ce que les hommes pensent.
Une fois que tout a été fini,
celui qui a le plus aidé
a été le brave Chorangyi.
C'est moi.
Seuls les dieux taoïstes savent
ce que je vaux vraiment.
Seuls les dieux
Comment ça se passe avec le film ?
On a mis le feu sur le plateau, ça
fait un mois qu'on ne tourne plus.
C'est dur de percer
dans ce domaine.
On dit que l'actrice principale
a été remplacée.
Vous disiez m'aimer.
Était-ce un mensonge ?
Je me suis mentie à moi même.
Alors adieu mon amour.
Coupez ! Excellent !
C'est bien d'avoir changé
le rôle principal.
Ça sent l'Oscar !
Bon travail !
- Vraiment ?
- Oui, bien sur !
- Dépêche-toi, pousse !
- J'arrive.
- Hé, tu es revenue ?
- Hi, Do-bin !
- Oui, mais ta jambe, ça va ?
Tout va bien !
Je ne sais pas comment tu as fait
mais on ne devient pas actrice
du jour au lendemain !
- Comment va votre jambe ?
- Elle va bien.
- Qu'est-ce que...
- Hé !
- Quoi ?
- Oh !
Vous étiez
tous les trois complices !
Va les chercher.
Oui madame.
Et toi, tu vas aller leur dire
que tu démissionnes.
Cette station balnéaire débile
que tu aimes. Dis-lui que tu y vas.
J'en ai assez entendu.
Vous savez à qui vous parlez ?
Tu as déjà de nouveaux agents ?
Ce sont ces hommes ?
Oui. Ils sont dangereux.
Elle dit avoir été enlevée
il y a un mois, c'est exact ?
- Il y a vingt six jours exactement.
- Oui.
C'est vrai.
Je peux me changer ?
Bien sûr.
Je vais t'aider !
On ferait mieux de les amener au
commissariat. Agent Kim, par là !
Amener qui et où ?
Ne regardez pas, elle se change !
Ne vous inquiétez pas maître,
nous attendons dehors.
Quelque chose cloche.
Ouvrez les rideaux !
- Il y a une sortie de secours ?
- Non monsieur.
Mais où sont-ils passés ?
Moi je sais ! Ils sont là !
Où sommes-nous ?
J'aime bien te renifler.
Je m'appelle Chorangyi.
Attends-moi !
J'ai toujours rêvé de venir ici.
Avec quelqu'un.
Pourquoi ici ?
Je ne suis pas sûre.
Ça m'a toujours attiré.
Cette musique
me rappelle quelque chose.
Est-ce que je vois...
ce moment dans l'avenir ?
Est-ce que c'est...
l'océan ?